now the Prime Minister has promised more
than 40 million pounds of funding to fix
flood defences overwhelmed by storms
this Christmas but the government's been
accused of failing to grasp the severity
of climate change on which the extreme
weather is being blamed amongst those
critics of course is the green party's
leader Natalie Bennett and she's with me
right now and very good to see you and I
just want you to respond to what we
heard from the shadow transport second
be there because I know you were
listening with great interest I'm going
to be stealing any votes off the Green
Party then on their airport policy I
guess well I think you it's very
disappointing to see such a weak
position there yo it's very clear that
we cannot have further airport capacity
in the southeast you expansion that
doesn't fit with the climate change
targets the impact of climate change
we're already seeing what a one-degree
world looks like one degree warmed world
looks like that's what we're living in
now you expansion of aviation is no way
forward what we need to be doing and
also was very disappointing he had a
very weak response to some cycling you
what we need to do with you we are also
opposed to hs2 so entirely disagree on
that point to yet we want to see
investment in transport we want to see
investments starting with walking and
cycling local buses which have been
slashed around the country one of the
things I find where I go around the
country is people say you my life has
just been thrown into turmoil but the
fact there's not a local bus service
anymore how do people get to work how do
people get to community events how do
people see their family when they've
lost their local bus services and of
course we desperately need to improve
rail services in the north but not with
the hs2 which is bringing focusing money
people resources even more on London but
instead your cross-country east-west
routes routes that link up parts of the
north and encourage development they're
not bring even more focus down on London
well let's talk about chain you touched
on there of course the major part of
this interview about the flooding and
you have no doubt then that this is
linked climate change because you must
we must be aware muscle me that no one
single event or group events can be
definitively linked to climate change
and there are thoughtful scientists they
are saying well you know there's been
this big shift in El Nino and Pacific
currents and warm airs and an actual
fact that's not necessarily unusual of
course any single event is weather but
what we know is under climate change
we're going to see more extreme weather
events more offer
and particularly particularly rainfall
and you're there's some basic physics
here which is that warm air holds more
water that's the nature of it and what
we're seeing is you know six of the
seven Huestis years on record in Britain
have been since the year 2000 we are in
we are in extreme conditions things are
changing there's one calculation that
says see a forty percent of the blame
for this is climate change that's just
one person's calculation but there were
forty percent more likely because of
this so these are you know this
calculations out there but there's no
xplode out at all that we are now living
in a one degree warm world it is now
overall one degree warmer than it was in
the industrial times and one of the
really exciting things of last year was
that we got the agreement in Paris
better than was expected to agree to
work towards limiting that increase to
1.5 and that's really important and
that's a huge step forming globally of
course sadly just to bring you back to
flooding and flood defences because you
know we know the pot is limited the
spending part is limited and these
events are called once in a year events
and their effect specific parts of
course you know let's not denigrate
let's not play down the effects on
people but the vast majority of the UK
is not affected on a grand scale by
flooding but the money comes from all
their taxes we have to think about where
we want to prioritize don't wait and the
fact is of course you're pretty well all
around the UK there's risk certainly
from localized flooding and one of the
issues and where you I've really said
that David Cameron has utterly failed
over the six years that he's been Prime
Minister is not just flood defenses
which have clearly been yo cut away
unreasonably and left people at risk
people who are suffering right now but
there's also the much broader issue of
how that we ensure that that we reduce
the risk of flooding all around the
country and that means looking at total
catchment management looking at planting
trees particularly in upland areas
looking at managing water flows in urban
areas sustainable urban drainage rural
sustainable drainage schemes that
basically I was down on the Somerset
Levels last month that the slogan is
slow the flow if you if a lot of rain
falls and if you hold that on the land
that it's falling on for longer then you
much less likely to get flooding
downstream and the government has simply
failed to make any progress in that area
I just wanted to ask you about you know
we've got a lot of elections coming up
for your party
they Scotland London local elections
anyway let's not leave that out your
vote go doesn't seem to be holding up
doesn't mean we just had that snapshot
in Oldham didn't we were there was a
three-quarter cut in the number of
people who voted green from the general
election just to that violation well of
course what's coming up in terms of the
elections coming up is first of all in
the London Assembly the welsh assembly
and the scottish parliament with our
sister party up there these are fair
proportional representation elections
people know that their vote counts and
I'm expecting to see very strong results
in all of those but what we're also
seeing is it is local council elections
up and down the country and each one of
these is a local race and of course the
green party last year our membership
more than trebled we've seen you scores
of new parties up and down the country
who are out yesterday I was I was up in
cannock you know where we've got a party
local party that's barely a year old
doing great work working with with a
local alliance save our countryside you
so up and down the country we're looking
to really grow our number of green
counselors to turn the green surge of
last year the trebling of our membership
into green seats but I mean you know it
is being said isn't it and not just from
those associated with your party that
there is a bit of a dangerous there from
a call been led Labour Party that
they're cutting the ground from under
usually them much more to the left well
I think it's interesting I mean we just
we've seen me at the transport interview
that we've just seen whether it's a
chest to airport runways or cycling
we've just seen some very clear lines in
the sand of division on that not if you
stick to your environmental agenda well
but if we also stick to the fact that
we've said we want to get rid of the
work capability assessment for the to
hit disabled people very hard that's
something we've been campaigning on very
strongly you look at the European
referendum that's looking coming up yet
where the people who are saying we
celebrate the free movement of people in
the EU we're saying that we in terms of
treatment of asylum seekers treatment of
refugees we need a very different
approach we're saying that very
different things to other part just want
a quick thought on on Saudi Arabia in a
pretty unsavoury regime terms of those
number of executions do you think we
ought to start looking at tys even
cutting ties with it I think very much
so and the place to start is we should
stop immediately arms exports to Saudi
Arabia I mean this is a regime that is
behavior
you know in total disregard for any kind
of human rights any respect for
international law you the sheikh nemir
al- who they executed the US yep the UN
secretary-general was campaigning for
his release this is a peaceful democracy
campaigner he was just being executed
and I think one of the things there
hasn't been much focus on perhaps
because it is so awful is they displayed
the bodies of those executed men on
gibbets after they were executed that's
the kind of regime that where fawning to
we're treating as a friend and Ally
we're bending over backwards and the
government's response to this has been
totally inadequate you know it's very
disturbing okay Natalie Bennett good to
see you thank you very much